for the last two decades some of the
biggest gaming news and reveals have
come during the Electronic Entertainment
Expo or e3 the yearly video game
industry trade show where the newest
titles and products are on full display
many for the first time but even though
the show has drawn tens of thousands of
people to its convention centers every
summer the show itself has gone through
a whole lot of changes during this
22-year long run so let's take a look
back at the history of III and maybe
laugh at all the dorky 90s outfits while
we're at it
strap yourself in cuz we're gone III
okay so here we are in 1985 the gaming
industry was attempting to recover from
the market crash two years prior and CES
the Consumer Electronics Show was the
primary convention for hardware makers
to show off the newest consoles and
games video games would continues to
thrive after the release of the Nintendo
Entertainment System
but there still wasn't a dedicated
gaming convention for all the newest
releases for the next 10 years they had
to share the spotlight with the latest
televisions cameras and the Batmobile
and so that brings us to 1995 right in
the middle of the decade a 19-year old
Tiger Woods was dominating the amateur
golf world
Bill Gates was busy launching the newest
version of Windows with Jay Leno for
some reason but more importantly the
interactive digital software Association
now known as the Entertainment Software
Association or ESA was quietly putting
together the biggest video game trade
show in the world I'm Kurt Loder with
MTV News connoisseurs of video games
computer effluvia and all the latest an
electronic gizmo maniac converged on Los
Angeles last week the annual Electronic
Entertainment Expo that are known as e3
okay 50,000 members of the press in its
first year is hardly quiet
in fact the gaming wall got an earful of
big console announcements from the three
biggest publishers at the time Sony Sega
and Nintendo during e3 1985 Sony
revealed the original Playstations
release date and price the Sega Saturn
for some reason started immediately
shipping to retailers and Nintendo's
showcase the Virtual Boy I guess one out
of three ain't bad and that was in
addition to all the third-party
developers who also showed up 3do Capcom
activision EA and Squaresoft all
attended but their presence was dwarfed
by none other than acclaim who brought
in over 15 different games to the show
III s first year ended up being one of
the biggest game conventions to date and
encouraged the organizers to continue
having the show in Los Angeles every
summer and they did for the next two
years at least while sunny California
might have been the perfect spot for e3
due to some unfortunate negotiation
problems the location was actually moved
to Atlanta Georgia for 97 and 98
nevertheless III continued to grow in
size and upon returning to the LA
Convention Center the attendance
remained at a steady 60 to 70,000 people
strong that's quite a lot of people but
there were quite a lot of games there as
well d 399 featured Sega's new Dreamcast
console in full force as well as some
previews of Sony's new Playstations at
e3 2002 software giant Microsoft who
were preparing for the release of their
first video game console the Xbox and
you'll be able to get a box just like
this with that popular III 2001 was the
final appearance of Sega as a console
maker after making the decision to focus
on software only but we also got the
first look at Nintendo's latest system
the Gamecube as well as the first
trailer for super smash brothers melee
which by the way is still one of the
biggest fighting games today so the new
big three Sony Nintendo and no Microsoft
kind of cruised along for a few years it
wasn't until III 2006 that Sony decided
to make history with one of the weirdest
press conferences ever game is powered
by Namco it's Ridge Racer Ridge Racer
remember that one the stages of the game
will also be based on famous battles
which took actually took place in
ancient Japan
so here's this giant enemy crab was the
unintentional goofiness of Sonja's press
conference the tipping point probably
not but the giant enemy crab sure didn't
help anything
hop on its stomach and you attack its
weak point for massive damage the
following year citing budget issues
among some publishers then ESA president
Doug Lowenstein announced that III would
now be a smaller more intimate event
with an invite-only list of about 10,000
people this shift
essentially shut out many bloggers and
non industry professionals that had
attended the show in previous years but
with a new look also came a new name III
media and business summit also III that
year wasn't held at the TIBCO Los
Angeles Convention Center
nor was it held in any sort of central
location at all it was actually spread
across different venues and locations in
Santa Monica and if you weren't part of
the industry at the time you probably
wouldn't have even realized it was
happening gone were the gaudy displays
and sensory overload of previous year's
and in their place where hotel ballrooms
and Jamie Kennedy from Neversoft which
wasn't that the first name for Viagra
despite the changes being made to try
and improve the show it was still an
exceedingly tough time for III with
Simms creator Will Wright saying that
the conference quote almost feels like a
zombie at this point but hey at least we
got a few memes out of the deal my body
my body is ready thankfully for Will
Wright and many other people who once
enjoyed attending III the show was
actually opened back up to a larger
audience in 2009 with over 40,000 people
coming back to check out the latest
games such as Metal Gear Rising Final
Fantasy 14 and Super Mario Galaxy 2 the
slight misstep didn't seem to matter all
that much as e3 continued to be the
biggest name in gaming trade shows
though there has been no shortage of
awkward press conferences in the years
since
[Music]
there was ubisoft's in 2015 do you have
a me me one up you want to pitch we had
mr. caffeine in 2011 everyone do it with
me
and of course Konami's in 2010 this is
not the originary hack-and-slash anymore
this is an extreme haggis fest at all
but as we all know III isn't about memes
mostly with a 22 year history behind it
there have also been changes in the way
publishers approached the show
companies like Ubisoft have continuously
attempted to bring more personality and
humor to their press conferences though
their success rate is up for debate and
Nintendo stopped doing live press
conferences entirely in 2013 to focus
under pre-recorded showcases dubbed a
Nintendo Direct and in 2017 III itself
changed everything by opening its doors
to the public for the very first time
meaning that anyone was able to buy
tickets and attend the show but even
through all ups and downs III has been
and continues to be a place for media
publishers and now the gaming public to
gather and celebrate videogames and all
their wonderful and sometimes weird
glory so here's two more III two more
jaw-dropping reveals more awkward
moments and goofy press conferences and
most importantly more games next check
out our full body motion capture so as
you can see when I start making move
into my avatar it instantly mimics me on
screen you ever wonder what the bottom
of an avatar shoe looks like well BAM
there it is
[Music]
you